- So what advice would I have for someone
who wants to be an entrepreneur?
So everyone's path is different,
so take anything I have to say
with a grain of salt.
But a lot of folks think
of entrepreneurship as,
"Hey, I have a new idea for a business,"
whether it's a restaurant,
or a new technology company,
a new social network,
whatever it might be,
and they put a lot of
emphasis on the idea itself.
And I think most
entrepreneurs would tell you
that a lot more depends
not only on the idea
but the execution of the idea,
and really just how ready is the world,
is the market, for your idea?
And so my advice would be, especially
if you're early in your career,
try to build as many skills as you can,
and to be an entrepreneur,
you have to be a little bit
of a jack of all trades.
So know your finance.
Know your accounting.
Know your marketing,
And you don't have to know
it necessarily academically,
but know it intuitively.
Pay attention to how
other people are doing it.
Think about your strategy.
And wherever your area of interest is,
if it's to start a restaurant,
get to know that business
really, really, really well.
Work at a restaurant at all levels.
If your goal is to work in tech,
work at some tech companies.
Get to know that really, really well.
Get to know not just the technology,
not just the product management,
not just the design, but
the sales aspect of it.
Get to know the management aspect of it.
And the whole time that
you're building yourself up,
that you're working in
industry and learning
these various skills,
make sure that you have
some time to fiddle.
The best entrepreneurial ideas
that I've seen are the ones
where folks get to know a space well
through their craft, and
then they have an idea,
and then they're able to have a little bit
of time to test out that idea,
not only build it, not only prototype it,
but put it out there somehow
and see how it the market responds.
And if the market is
responding very favorably,
if people are saying,
"Wow, I want more of this.
"How can I get it?"
Then I think you're on to something.
And all of those skills
that you would have built up
over those many years,
not only will they help
you execute on the idea,
but they'll help you convince other people
that you're ready to execute on the idea,
which is maybe just as important,
potential investors, people that you need
to co-found your venture with,
and also, my last point is
know what your weak points are.
As you experience all of these dimensions
of starting a business, if you know that,
hey maybe the marketing
isn't my thing, know that.
And then you could find
someone who's good at it,
who can complement you, if you're like,
"Hey, I like the entrepreneurial side,
"but scaling up a business
isn't my cup of tea."
Find great operators who
can help you scale it up.
So that's my two cents.
Take it all with a grain of salt.